John blitt was with JD he went over to
JD's house to watch the game and JD has
two levels while watching the Bengals
subdued JD and high octane JD and here
is a montage of JD watching the game
this [__] game oh my god oh first
down one day no come on Pearl come on
offense no get it [__] bro God damn it
get him there you go
the [__] are we doing oh god dude
[__] damn it please get to stop
please no Mom for the love of Christ
please no are you [__] kidding me it
doesn't matter that doesn't [__]
matter help me out here do you own the
team or are you just a fan I understand
[Music]
[__] believable
wow here is the moment the Bengals lose
and uh JD is not happy
I have Bangles
Bangles are gonna lose it's that's not
good how long will it take you to get
over this
I I don't know John
after that [__] it was the [__]
penalty but whatever
yeah the Bengals are just gonna lose
here
it's snowing yeah that's not okay NFL
gets what they want [__]
Chief's in there it's whatever
immediately he's got the excuse why they
went lost
wow that wasn't a [__] penalty by
the way he pushed him out of bats they
were clearly out of bounds and he first
of all the play was dead and he pushed
him clearly they were like in the bleach
football expert all of a sudden hey I
even knows the rules I agree with Ralph
shut up Richard